[Music]  she's mine  [Music]  [Music]  we were scum trash refuse that didn't  fit into the system  until someone had the bright idea that  recycling us to serve science the arts  are not in our favor but when my work is  accomplished when perfection isn't she  then what  fly away I know I look like a witch  you're foxy and you know it this mission  came Turner ashamed to some type of  glory I can't do this flying around them  you like to you  [Music]  the sensation moving backwards  even though moving forwards getting  further from what's getting nearer  [Music]  there's nothing to fear everything's  great the laws of nature  now pay for it  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]